I come here not to dispute the suggestion...
...that I haven't yet achieved enough in my life.
First of all, Michelle concurs with that assessment.
She has a long list of things that I have not yet done,...
...waiting for me when I get home.
But more than that, I come to embrace...
...the notion that I haven't done enough in my life.
I heartily concur,...
...I come to affirm that one's title,...
...even a title like President of the United States...
...says very little about how well one's life has been led.
That no matter how much you've done or how successful you've been,...
...there's always more to do,...
...always more to learn and always more to achieve.
And I wanna say to you today,...
...graduates, class of 2009,...
...that despite having achieved a remarkable milestone in your life,...
...despite the fact that you and your families are so rightfully proud,...
...you too cannot rest on your laurels.
Not even some of those remarkable young people who were introduced earlier.
Not even that young lady who's got four degrees yet today.
You can't rest.
Your own body of work is also yet to come.